a most arrangement of the Greek masks  the mask of comedy is placed a little  higher than the mask of tragedy and why  not you ask after after seeing what a  laugh we do toward lifting the human  spirit the next award goes to a higher  practitioner of comedy a man who in a  dazzling series of movies permanently  dislocated the funny bone of America but  he was more than a comedian he wasn't is  that most difficult of all things to be  a good citizen and it's silver jubilee  the Academy's pleased to announce the  voting of an honorary award to which  beloved freshman Harold Lloyd  thank you I'm most grateful and highly  honored to the Academy for this award  this is a very cherished moment you know  when you get one of your own they kind  of seem different this Bob said next  year they'll have glasses I guess I'm  just a year too soon thank you very much  you